this screenwriter of Megan has said her
original screenplay was way gorier than
the Final Cut of the film so can viewers
ever expect to see that blood-soaked
unrated version the answer may surprise
you the New Year in film has officially
kicked off with the campy horror
Thriller Megan from Universal Pictures
and blumhouse Productions this stylish
doll who lends the movie Her name became
an internet icon ahead of the movie's
January 2023 release thanks to the Glee
with which she kills as showcased in its
first trailer this preview particularly
intrigued fans with a scene in which
Megan sachets with a handcrafted machete
toward her next victim building
anticipation for the horror comedy early
on the full movie lived up to the hype
by leaning into its campiness earning an
impressive 94 score on Rotten Tomatoes
This suggests an extremely promising
start as the film premieres to
enthusiastic theater goers looking for a
bloody good time Megan is notably
produced by genre veteran James 1 whose
recent work has helped Usher in a new
generation of horror I get accused of
being the master of killer doll movies
one is credited with the story of Megan
alongside akayla Cooper who serves as
its principal screenwright the duo
previously collaborated on the
mind-boggling action horror flick
malignant and are teaming up again for
upcoming sequel project the nun too as
it turns out Megan in its final form is
decidedly less bloody than its initial
screenplay which Cooper revealed might
manifest as an unrated cut viewers will
hopefully see released before a possible
Megan sequel the final trailer for Megan
gave viewers a terrifying look at its
titular doll's proficiency for killing
and the deadly tactics she employs
against a few unfortunate victims who
threaten either her or her best friend
Katie in an interview published just
before the film's release radar Kayla
Cooper told the LA Times that an unrated
cut of Megan may already be in the works
featuring even more violence Cooper said
of the film's screenplay there should be
an unrated version at some point I heard
it is on the books but yes it was way
gorier her body count in the script was
higher than in the movie it wasn't a
Gabriel from malignant scale Massacre
but she did kill a bunch more people
Cooper also revealed that James the
one's input spared several lives as he
credited her with writing compelling
characters undeserving of their deaths
as initially planned Cooper told the LA
Times I was merciless but then again
that is me my humor is extremely dark
the acclaimed writer also explained why
the movie was eventually toned down to
adhere to an intended PG-13 rating once
Megan's dance went viral the teenage
audience it developed online became
Central to its marketing campaign that
said Cooper's interview hints that we
may possibly see a bloodier unrated cut
released in the future preserving
Megan's Rampage as initially conceived
for future fans of the film in an
interview gamesradar published just
prior to the January 6 2023 premiere of
Megan director Gerard Johnstone
explained that following a precedent set
by Sam Raimi horror comedy dragged me to
hell he decided to reshoot certain
scenes in order to secure a PG-13 rating
Johnstone told the outlet making it
PG-13 was something that happened after
the fact but it was always so close to
PG-13 anyway what I was really stoked
about is that when we reshot those
scenes they were more effective while
Johnstone may be a firm believer in
Megan as a PG-13 film plenty of fans are
nevertheless interested in the possible
unrated cut that akayla Cooper floated
for example in a Reddit Thread about
Cooper's comments one user proposed that
one particular scene would have
benefited from a higher Gore quotient
meanwhile another person wrote on
Twitter that they want to see a more
detailed version of a certain
character's death in an unrated release
while Cooper may have mentioned the
prospect of an unrated Megan there's not
yet any official word from either
Universal or blumhouse of course if fan
interest remains High Enough this
bloodier version of Megan could very
well see the light of day
[Music]